coming off two of the best seasons of tv
in recent memory the expectations for
season three of succession was sky high
people became enamored with its cast of
misfit characters you can't make a
tomlet without breaking some greggs it's
snappy dialogue rome you couldn't get a
job in a [ __ ] burger joint let alone
a fortune 500 without some nepotism and
the allure of watching the uber elite
wrestle for power go out and see how you
like it
[ __ ] off and during its enforced
two-year hiatus the show only grew in
popularity it developed a reputation as
one of the best written well-casted
dramas since the likes of the sopranos
and breaking bad i think
this is the day
his reign ends
unfortunately with high expectations
comes inevitable disappointment and
there were some elements of season 3
that deviated from the polished
excellence of the first two seasons
but before we discuss season 3 in
general i thought we'd get back to
basics and focus on what makes this show
so fantastic the characters and their
pursuit of power whilst the expansive
character development peripheral
subplots and loquacious legal gymnastics
can make succession seem complex if you
strip it all back it's just a bunch of
people trying to win every character has
a different goal different obstacles and
different strategies some work
i
[ __ ] win and some don't my son
that was your best shot
you last night therefore let's go
through the main characters and try and
work out who won and who lost in season
three before discussing the season in
general hit me up below with your
thoughts who did you think won season
three let's start with the big dog logan
roy and he was at the center of
everything this season including his um
uh
his assistant and while he started and
finished as the king of waystar his
level of influence shifted substantially
throughout season three to start his
biggest opponent was kendall who had
just aired waystar's dirty little
secrets
the truth is that my father is a
malignant presence
this triggered a few key events first
the doj started hunting for gross
negligence and misconduct within waystar
this caused logan to flee the country
and install jerry as interim ceo as a
fleeing quasi felon i'd say this was his
absolute low point of the season do you
want a room yes i want a [ __ ] room
the shareholders then called for a vote
of no confidence forcing shiv to make a
deal with sandy and stewie this is this
is good with logan
i can sell it he lost to president
gained a president disposed of the doj
but then finally succumbed to a bigger
fish in matson go on
talk to me the season ended with him
apparently setting control of the
company to the gojo ceo for a hefty
payout while cutting all tyres with the
kids oh go on go on [ __ ] off you nosy
[ __ ] pedestrians oh yeah he also
apparently can't die so there's a lot to
unpack on one hand logan never came away
from a business deal empty-handed whilst
there were occasionally better outcomes
than what he settled for for example
matson acquiring the company instead of
being a merger of equals there were
always worse outcomes he got a massive
fine from the doj so what no one went to
jail and he got away with it he lost the
support of the current president [ __ ]
[ __ ]
boom shakalaka hell yeah so what he
hand-picked the next president every
single conversation he made was a
calculated move to benefit him and his
legacy
this way no
for the judas as he said to roman in the
final episode
that's a deal
what have you got in your [ __ ] hand
on the other hand he lost two important
things this season first is the support
of his kids shiv roman and kendall are
now his enemies he made a deal to [ __ ]
them over and there's seemingly no
coming back from that while the
relationship aspect of this doesn't seem
to matter as he's an emotionless robot
who doesn't seem capable of love
strategically this could come back to
bite him however he also lost control of
waystar his russian office selling to
matson is because i feel like my bones
and maybe he's right maybe it's a good
idea to go out on top rather than slowly
bleed to death but waystar is his baby
his legacy and what's a few more billion
as kendall put it what are you gonna do
with the five bill
huh
put it on your pile with all your other
[ __ ] bill in my mind this feels a bit
like him winning the battle with the
kids only to lose the war when he
realizes what he's forfeit we've also
got to point out that the deal with
matson isn't done stewie and sandy still
have a huge stake in waystar and
probably have the juice to block it
remembering that shiv gave them an extra
board scene in episode 5. who knows the
deal could still blow up in his face
having said this i still think logan is
a big winner from this season instead of
being in jail or dying he's rich free
warded off all challenges and is still
trying to impregnate another assistant
now for the second most important
character this season
you're going to sue greenpeace
like your style greg despite the amount
of exposure the charitable organization
received throughout the season and the
250 million donation from euan they did
also get sued by greg i have some beef
with korean peace
long story but
they're bad as the financial and
reputational losses from this court case
could exceed 250 million dollars i think
i'm gonna have to say that they're a
loser in season three
the wayward prince had a tumultuous
season three and lost all manner of
strategic battles his attempt to wrestle
waystar away from logan failed
spectacularly as his credibility and
confidence slowly created and his case
with the doj quickly turned to dust he
unsuccessfully tried to sway shiv roman
connor greg tom my hunch
is that you're going to get [ __ ]
matson josh and frank and was thoroughly
outmaneuvered by logan at every turn i
just wanted to tell you that your dad
actually already left so however kenny's
biggest obstacle throughout season three
was himself weighed down by years of
crippling self-doubt and now haunted by
the death of the waiter in season one
kendall's behavior was
erratic to say the least just [ __ ] go
nut nut adopting something of a faux god
complex he paraded around with a veil of
artificial confidence hiding behind
lavish parties and self-aggrandizing
tweets while in reality he was suffering
from anxiety doubt and the unending
sadness that he could no longer rely on
his family ken's arc is probably the
saddest in the show for this very reason
he feels the need to embody his father
to succeed but unlike logan he still has
a heart lacking the killer instinct and
relying instead on his unstable emotions
inevitably led to the collapse of his
coup as he fired his lawyer elected a
cash out from the company and almost
drowned therefore it's pretty hard to
mount a case that kendall did anything
but lose this season up to episode 8.
i actually think he's a winner because
of episode 9. being in the wilderness
seemed to crystallize what ken knew all
along he is not his father as he says in
episode 8 you're kind of
evil he now seems to appreciate how
miserable he was trying to imitate his
father instead he wants to be a real
person you're not a real person
you're not real rather than someone
whose life revolves around making moves
and the biggest factor his confession in
episode nine is [ __ ] lonely
hey
i'm all apart seem to lead to some sort
of absolution or rebirth as he teamed up
with shiv and roman you can handle us
been basically planning it since we were
four if he doesn't get in his own way
ken can be a worthy opponent for anyone
in this show and if he finally has some
support around him i think he's ready to
mess some people up in season four and
because of that i think he's a small
winner
all right now we get into the more
definitive category as shiv has been
losing for about 15 episodes thanks for
all the [ __ ] help as always ever
since she spoke out at nan pierce's in
season two it's been pretty obvious that
logan doesn't want her to take over oh
for [ __ ] sake dad just tell him it's
gonna be me
she's been given false promises keeps
making small mistakes and overreaching
and logan consequently moved on to roman
as his most reliable child friend
doesn't like you boo hoo boo hoo dad
wants to fire you
and yet she kept crawling back to him
this season acquiescing to logan's
demands in exchange for a pointless
conversation and a ceremonial title
siobhan
are you part of this family or not and
while yes it's true that she fought back
more and more until finally taking a
stand in episode nine dad once matson is
calling the shots we're [ __ ] the
motives and strategy of her character
were really unclear and contradictory
all season and this was incredibly
frustrating as a viewer i'll talk about
the writing for season 3 in a bit but i
think shiv is probably the worst written
character in the show and not because of
the dialogue or the acting sarah snook
is doing a great job it's just the lack
of consistency with her character i
don't think the writers know what they
want shiv to be she is occasionally
presented as a strategic mastermind with
a good read on public reaction and the
most sensible plan of attack you can't
just change your story i want to keep
you clean but then she does [ __ ] like
this let's just hope you don't do it
again right
no
lessons learned and then she saves the
deal with sandy or convinces ravenwood
to start nuking the president the thing
about us mark and you should know this
by now
we don't get embarrassed i assume that
like kendall her mistakes are meant to
be representative of shiv getting in her
own way but it reads more like an idiot
whose posturing is smart and gets lucky
a few times this extends to her
emotional intelligence as well as she is
occasionally presented as a caring
doting sister staging ken's intervention
but is also completely unaware of the
pain she is causing tom
even though i don't love you and yes i
know that the tom shiv marriage is a
topic of much debate he married her to
raise his social standing so he can't
complain too much blah blah blah but she
is objectively cruel in season three
this cruelty ironically leads to shiv
roman and kendall's downfall in episode
9 as tom sells them out so she has to be
classified as a loser next up we've got
another important character how's the
wi-fi ah i sacrificed a few goats so it
seems to be working despite the bad
wi-fi tuscany was a big winner if you
didn't see some of these places and want
to go to italy immediately you are a
genuine psychopath
[Music]
season one was kendall season season two
was shift season and season three was
roman roy's season each season saw a
different sibling take center stage and
increase responsibility within waystar
as they clamored for logan's approval
and i thought that roman's character
development this season was probably
head to head with tom as the best in
season three he went from the kid in
management training to logan's most
reliable ally wheeling and dealing with
tech giants like we're all obviously
hugely looking forward to my father
dying talking to presidents
how are you doing
bribing tattoo men and taking dick pics
yeah that's his
dick he's
sent you a picture of his dick and
throughout all this he developed a sense
of worth of independence of validation
which was really fun to see because
while roman is clearly still a dick and
did some pretty awful things this season
at least he's evolved into something of
a competent businessman in order for the
episode 9 sibling team up to have legs
going into season 4 roman needed to take
the next step because now all three kids
have at least shown some semblance of
business acumen and guile and the
prospect of kendall shiv and roman in
their final forms presents at least a
reasonable challenge for the behemoth
that is logan roy gong
[ __ ] off
i have you beat however the real growth
for roman came in the realization that
he had to finally break free from logan
much like kane in season one he realized
that logan doesn't see them as kids he
sees them as pawns to move around the
board that's why when roman finally
stood up to his dad in episode 9 it was
so satisfying compare these two scenes
you better be smelling your [ __ ]
armpit romulus i thought we had this
figured out
yeah it just might be better you know if
we all here it took 23 episodes for
roman to finally break free and pick a
side of his own volition and it was
awesome now we've got to mention that it
wasn't a super great season for rome
personally his girlfriend from season 2
tabitha was completely written out of
the show and his relationship with jerry
has blown up completely she found a new
guy and then essentially torpedoed their
relationship by reaffirming her loyalty
to logan how does it serve my interests
however i still think romulus is one of
the biggest winners of season three he
talks [ __ ] for nine episodes climbed the
ranks and broke free from papa bear
winner i like conor roy
alright now we're on to everyone's
favorite presidential candidate and like
roman khan showed some real growth this
season not only did he finally convince
willa to marry him i'm smiling now
great like you said yes he evolved from
the sibling's punching bag into an
assertive active member of the family
the season opened with him being brushed
aside by logan as an afterthought once
again can you hold the fork yeah can you
keep this all secure but instead of just
lying down and taking it connor was
happy to go against his father's wishes
meeting up with the other kids pursuing
his political career and blackmailing
logan into obtaining an influential
position in the company and coming in
and hitting three four major
achievements and then getting out he
also finally said what we've all been
thinking for a few seasons and blasted
the other siblings in episode nine i am
the eldest son it's hard to say which
side of the war he's on so his position
of power is a bit tenuous but he did
evolve from a meme into kind of a real
person this season therefore he's a
small winner in my book my partner is
cold and he'd like to keep his [ __ ]
coat on much like marsha i don't think
we saw enough of willow this season she
was great in every single scene provides
a valuable reference point for what a
mere mortal looks like amongst these
otherworldly beings and she really does
feel like part of the family now in
terms of whether she won or lost i don't
know it all depends on whether you like
connor she's going to marry him and get
a [ __ ] load of money to fund her
terrible play so i think you've got to
say she's a winner no doubt there will
be an airtight prenup so she can't
divorce him for a big paycheck but
whatever you'd go girl greg you marry
her your plane crash away from becoming
europe's weirdest king alright big tommy
wamsgan's had an incredible season he
was erratic
spent most of the season researching
prisons i've read the prison blocks greg
i know and seemed to keep getting pushed
around by shiv however the writers kept
dropping breadcrumbs that he was playing
the long game and his decision to sell
out the siblings in episode 9 was proof
that he's finally chosen aside to be
fair he was pretty consistently team
logan throughout offering to be the
blood sacrifice i go to your dad and i i
offer myself up as the beating post
telling kenny's never seen logan lose
and i've never seen logan get [ __ ]
once and his final betrayal will have
garnered immense favor from logan at the
end of the day tom's main goal is to
move up the corporate ladder that's been
the thread for three seasons despite his
clear love for shiv and need for human
connection which he invariably gets
through his relationship with greg tom
seeks validation through his position
within the company he wants power and
recognition and therefore all
conversations come back to him where do
i fit in chef well high up tom i don't
know whether you think tom won or lost
in season three comes down to what you
think about his relationship with shiv i
truly believe he loves her as he refuses
to leave despite her cruel dismissive
mind games kind of got into the realms
of that you don't love me
okay well what happens in sex vegas but
he was also clearly using their
relationship to advance his own career
he knew he was marrying into the viper's
nest and by the sheer amount of times he
asked what this meant for him he's
clearly thinking about himself first and
foremost however he now has a bit of
autonomy a reasonably loyal minion in
greg and back the winning side escaping
an abusive relationship and finishing on
top i'd say that constitutes as a win
but now we've got to talk about tom's
true love this is like oj
i mean except if oj never killed anyone
after pulling the strings in the
background for season one and two greg
took a back seat in season three to the
point that he didn't really do anything
most of his screen time was devoted to
flirting bumbling and groveling to both
sides in order to somehow avoid jail
time i was wondering
since i mean it looks like you're
going anyway therefore it was a very
stressful season for gregory he was
openly insulted by all of the roys maybe
stop feeding on your own [ __ ] family
and try sucking some blood elsewhere
fell out with kendall lost his 250
million dollar inheritance i'm giving
all my money to greenpeace great um
what and was moved into a storage
cupboard for his office on the plus side
he did barter a deal with logan in order
to head up the parks division in korea
what's it worth
in terms of the me of it all but that
job then became completely irrelevant as
he pledged his undying loyalty to tom in
the finale i suppose the other silver
lining was that he did finally learn
that there are repercussions for his
actions with ewan providing his most
important life lesson to date because
you need to take yourself seriously kid
however as he didn't progress his career
holds a tenuous position in our
uncertain organization depending on what
the bottom of the top means and remained
mainly stagnant and stressed i'm
actually going to say greg was a loser
in season three oh well at least he's
still got tom and his watch wow
is that the time
excuse me useful for telling the time
and wooing foreign royalty the watch was
an undisputed winner this season
don't want pictures of my deck no okay
season three saw jerry ascend to main
character status which was heaps of fun
she formed an alliance with rome which
saw her become interim ceo but the rest
of the season saw a slow decline in her
influence in the company as her
authority was routinely undermined by
the real boss logan government isn't a
[ __ ] pez dispenser you don't push a
button if something pops out the other
day yes i am well
she also got tangled up in dick pic gate
with roman which led to shiv questioning
her long-term credentials at waystar
however at the end she was still on the
winning side eating [ __ ] like the other
lackeys i'm focused on whatever outcome
best serves the financial interests of
the shareholders she's a winner for
becoming a main character but a loser
because she has to work for logan and
this extends to carl and frank as well
they're losers for having to deal with
the stress of this job day to day it's
not worth it guys go like i don't know
open an ice cream shop or something i
feel like i'm taking a [ __ ] in the
guggenheim y'all could we make a note in
the minutes that he's watching honestly
these guys were losers for a few reasons
number one they just weren't on screen
enough i love stewie and the new sandy
is a good addition as well even for the
big shareholder vote episode they were
barely used and that seems like a
massive oversight by the writers number
two they kept getting undercut by logan
sure they made a sweet deal and got some
board seats and money in episode five
but other than that they came off as
completely incompetent their agreement
stipulated that they were going to be
included in the decision-making process
we were supposed to be inside deal
making and that waystar couldn't use
private jets anymore well they're still
rocking around in pjs and sandy and
stewie were routinely left out of
decision making after stewie came across
as this no-nonsense business wizard who
was one of the only people unafraid to
face logan head-on in seasons one and
two oh he's got a more pressing matter
than us taking his empire off his hands
him devolving into a clueless side
character was infuriating big loser i
was humiliated and things must be made
right i think marsha was only in three
scenes for the entire season three and
that sucks i didn't like her as a
character but as i said in my other
recap she's an incredible villain who
deserved way more screen time the
dynamic between marsha and the kids was
a fun little chess game and i wanted the
writers to lean into her evil side in
season three she's a [ __ ] and it's not
my problem if she wouldn't finish him to
be fair she did secure the bag pretty
early on in exchange for very little so
you could say her character won this
season but the fact that she was barely
sighted left her as a loser for me and
now for the new characters success
doesn't really interest me anymore it's
too easy
the ceo of gojo became a pivotal figure
in season three and in my mind he's what
kendall would be if he was more stable a
forward-thinking high-functioning
sociopath who is willing to say what he
thinks when will your father die
and is focused on progressive ideas as
he pissed on waystar's app and then
bought the company weeks later it's hard
to say he was anything but a winner
looking forward to seeing more of matson
kendall
do you think you're smarter than me
what do i what the top lawyer in the
world had a very short stay getting axed
by kendall in episode six and while she
then didn't have to deal with his
shenanigans anymore the inability to
control your client and then getting
fired probably isn't looked upon too
fondly in the legal world so she's a
loser
no it doesn't work like that can we take
a walk why is josh aronson even in the
show again i love it when any character
is willing to stand up to logan's
[ __ ] but why did we even need this
episode
okay give me more stewie instead or
something he was never sighted again
massive loser so if you want to ask me
out
then ask me uh comfrey looks to be
having the worst time every time we see
her and then she got dumped for italian
royalty loser carrie i guess you have a
[ __ ] medal kerry soon to have satan's
spawn insider terrible haircut has to
put up with logan huge l for kerry
alright that's enough characters i
didn't want to do like iverson and stuff
so on to the season itself season three
was interesting now i want to preface
this by saying i didn't think it was bad
and i also understand that production
was impacted by covert but without the
finale i thought the show lacked a lot
of the punch of the first two seasons
you can trust me you can't trust him
and yeah i know you can say that without
the finale a lot of shows would suck but
hear me out the first two seasons had
really clear simple narrative
progression in season one kendall tried
to overthrow an ailing logan and was
ousted twice you [ __ ] me
i changed my mind in season two the roys
had to band together to repel sandy and
stewie while the cruise scandal came to
light the end of season two seemed to
set up a very clear season three my
father keeps a watchful eye over every
inch of his whole empire kendall
possibly with the help of sandy and
stewie would try to overthrow logan
while waystar fights the legal
implications of the cruz scandal and
while that's what we got none of the
seemingly world-ending threats facing
waystar amounted to anything apart from
episode one when logan fled to sarajevo
the doj investigation into cruisers was
never anything more than a nuisance and
was gone by episode six the threat of a
shareholder revolt was quelled just as
quickly with a quick conversation
between shiv and sandy in episode 5 even
the health scares and almost deaths we
had this season when logan had a heart
attack and kendall almost drowned were
forgotten by the start of the next
episode and because this kept happening
the stakes in the show seemed almost
non-existent i kept getting invested in
the next big complication only for that
to fizzle out almost immediately you're
a [ __ ] [ __ ]
in fewer words i'd say this season had a
lot more empty episodes where the
narrative barely progressed now that's
not to say the whole thing sucked
episode 9 had an amazing complication as
the kids found out they were about to
lose control of the company stakes don't
get any bigger than that and the payoff
of shiv ken and rome finally teaming up
and confronting logan was incredible no
we can fight it out it'll it'll be fun
that will be fun
it's also worth pointing out that
narrative isn't everything even though
the narrative didn't necessarily
progress the characters were constantly
evolving throughout the season tom and
roman had incredibly impressive
character arcs we learned more about
jerry ken almost drove himself to death
and emerged a more complete man matson
is a compelling new character and say
what you want about consistency the show
is also always going to retain its
watchability due to the incredible
acting and script writing oh no scary
poppins is on maneuvers i'm a bad person
[ __ ] off kiddo
all these years he still has to play
maitre d at the bistro [ __ ] it's
very rare to watch a scene and not
marvel at some turn of phrase or one of
the actors expressions let's go see hans
christian ander [ __ ]
and see if he's been telling us [ __ ]
fairy tales so in summary season three
was still pretty good i for one am a
huge fan of ending shows on a high so i
hope they only have four or five seasons
but i think the potential of the kids vs
logan in season 4 is incredibly exciting
let's hope the writers stick to the
basics this time and pay off what was a
fantastic season finale anyway thank you
as always for watching and i'll see you
in the next one see you again
[Music]